As we mentioned before,
we are now going to form a kernel density estimate from our model for x.
This will formalize the concept of the histogram as a non-parametric model.
And in the next few videos we are going to see how to do this.
Non-parametric models are extremely useful to get from discrete data,
to probability to density functions or distributions.
For example, it is useful in signal processing,
in online data collection to build quick models, and in several other fields.
In our case, we are going to use a single variable x.
If x one, x two to xn are data points.
We're after a probability density function P of x.
That best describes the distribution from which x one,
x two, so on till x n could have been drawn from.
How do we go about doing this?